Speaker 1: And hey, speaking of people who
didn't do well in polls, Madison Cawthorn
has been back in the news pretty much for
about a week or so now because the guy just
can't stop having problems with his campaign
finances. And I know that seems weird, right?
Because the guy lost his primary. Obviously,
he's not running for office anymore. He's
he's a lame duck. He's going to be leaving at the
end of the year. But last week, it was revealed
that Madison Cawthorn is a month late. In filing
his most recent campaign finance disclosures.
We also know that in those disclosures.
Speaker 2: That are still waiting to be.
Speaker 1: Filed, he's got thousands of
dollars that he's spent at Chick-Fil-A,
thousands of dollars that he spent at cigar shops.
And what some of the other 21,000 for lodging in
Florida, $3,000 at a place called Papa's Beer. And
of course, thousands, hundreds of thousands of.
Speaker 2: Dollars in consulting fees
that he's paid out to his consultants,
who clearly did not do a very good job for him.
Speaker 1: But he's a month late and filed it.
And now, according to a new report from The Daily
Beast, we know why. Because as it turns out,
according to this new report, Madison Cawthorn is
out of money. The people working for his campaign
said it was basically dollar in, dollar out. Guy
raised millions, but he spent even more than that.
Now, you may not think that's a problem,
right? Ha, ha. You ran out of money.
Speaker 2: You're not going to be
reelected anyway, so you suck. It's
a little bit murkier than that, though, folks.
Speaker 1: You see, there's a law. Believe it
or not, we actually do still have a couple.
Speaker 2: Campaign finance laws out there.
Speaker 1: And one of them says that you can
raise money for both your primary race and
the general election race at the same
time. Good. However, you cannot touch
that general election money until you've won
your primary. And if you don't win your primary,
you have to pay all that money back to the.
Speaker 2: Donors who gave it to you?
The General Election Fund.
Speaker 1: Doesn't matter what happens with your
primary money. If you lose, you lose whatever.
But if you've raised money for a general election
and you lose your primary, all of the general
election money by law has to go back to the
people that gave it to you. And that makes sense,
right? That's actually protecting the donors.
Which explains why we have that law, because.
Speaker 2: It protects the wealthy
corporations pouring.
Speaker 1: Money in Madison. Cawthorn,
as I said, is out of money. And he had a
lot of money in his general election fund.
So put two and two together and you realize that
Madison Cawthorn can't afford to pay back all the
money that he is supposed to be paying back.
And that is according to the people who worked
with his campaign that spoke to The Daily Beast.
So Madison Cawthorn is in a lot of trouble here.
He's going to have to come up
possibly with millions of dollars
to return to his donors and that likely. Again,
we can't say for certain, but it is likely
why he hasn't gone ahead and filed his campaign
finance disclosures, because it would show that
he spent all the money that he's legally.
Speaker 2: Not allowed to spend.
Speaker 1: So in addition to
no longer being in Congress,
he may no longer be a free man if he continues
to spend money so frivolously that he's legally
not allowed to touch if he
does have any money left over.
Speaker 2: I'd say it's time
to spend that on a good lawyer.